[Music]
welcome
to the pewdiepie server things feel
similar yet so different oh my god this
is so weird
the tree of life is all wrong yeah again
have you spotted me i'm uh i'm on the
cover am i
i'm on marcia's account no one knows
it's me
so this is the pewdiepie server if you
are a member
tier three you can access it we'll have
survival coming soon
right now we have creative uh there's
two ways to enter creative one is to
jump the parkour
which is very easy as you can
tell or you could just click here again
you can just click here again here we go
so
uh all right so the everyone that joins
gets their own plot of land this is my
plot of land as you can tell
i spent a lot of time building this but
oh my god
has there been so many insane
buildings let me chunk up that chunk
distance
i'm gonna go this puts everything i know
it's creative though but this puts
everything i made
into shame look at this this is one area
they got freaking trees they got a photo
of me what the hell
have you seen this man no no i have not
so cool oh my god they did the whole
inside
shoe game huh oh my
god you can get beer what there's
oh it's a bed that's so creative let's
check upstairs
what in the world is that
look at this massive peepee temple
by powwow 97 one day build are you
serious
are you serious it's all decorated
inside
i'm so bad at building after looking at
all of these how do i get out of here i
can't stay in there i'm suffocating
god damn look at the freaking dragons
how do you build this god damn
oh it just became night not anymore
oh my god it's a long maya
it's coke it's a pewdiepie totem pole
it's glorious thai fighter
what do we have here some redstone where
do i start it
i did it guys oh we got an actual ikea
we got fanboy hooters
stinky let's check out the ikea
glorious wow so much furniture
they got toilets i wish i could had it
toilet
what is it dolphin drugs
i'll have some dolphin drugs thank you
very much oh yeah dolphins eat puffer
fish to get high i forgot about oh god
all right yeah it's setting in
that is a large peepee right there god
damn
look at all these landscape they're just
like hey i'm gonna build a waterfall
okay cool what is this oh oh
spoopy oh my god what is that
they built my animal crossing character
there he is in all his glory beautiful
i love it we got a tiny meatball
pathetic size meatball i should really
say
what is this supposed to be some video
game
i'm not a nerd we got naruto yotaro
pixel art
very cool
we got oh is this like a dragon in
progress
damn you just know survival is just
going to be pure madness look at this
god damn so cool someone put a qr code
and their spotify playlist
okay cute little house
england england hasn't invented anything
denmark oh
peepee poopoo rest in peace pee pee poo
poo
rest in nice doge whoa
let me check this from above god damn
that's so cool
oh my god everyone's joining in on it
i didn't even notice oh my god it
continues
forever professed wow
germany deutschland
a epic best building so far
someone decided to build a giant tree
[Music]
i'm gonna break the server it's all it's
all good this is sick
i agree hey we got some viking boats
and the penguin well that's the robot
from nintendo
yes a large ikea nice nice
no furniture what the hell man nate's oh
this is a parking lot oh okay i
understand
okay okay it's not finished
shame i rate this small pp of shame
terrible do better next ingo okay
nailed the swedish so you get a bonus oh
can i set this off am i a dick if i set
that off
i really want to set it off it's my it's
my uh
it's my server right i'm allowed to do
that oh my god
i'll do it after what's the coordinates
i'm sure they wouldn't mind i'm sure
they wouldn't mind
now that's six that's a sexy man right
there oh my god he's so beautiful
i love him whoa
oh my god dude you're putting all my
japaneseness to shame
what the hell did so cool
how how did you do this
how surprising oh my god i have a giant
waterfall coming
oh my god hey
nice nice nice nice it's like no matter
where i go everyone's building is great
except this one this one's bad
brazil come see i came to brazil guys i
did it what is this a castle oh my god
shadow of the colossus that's so cool oh
my god a giant ship
in progress small peepee whoa
hell yeah nice nice nice
they're so massive you don't realize
when you're just flying around just how
big these are
nice little swimming pool oh that's a
good oh spin
spin spin oh
oh oh a giant volcano island
yes oh my god that it just never ends
jesus christ dude this is insane
so cool oh my god it keeps happening
oh my god god damn it do i feel bad
all these buildings are better than
anything i've ever built
look at this love you periods oh thank
you
thank you floor gang nice that's the
best one so far
is this a boat in the glass whoa
[Music]
we got the splatter nice that's so cool
oh god i flew into the llama it's all
good
[Music]
doom guy very nice another i can't
i want to build an ikea now this one has
furniture
my god even has a line outside are these
the people that build it
ikea hello everybody my name is
markiplier i love ikea
irish screaming nice whoa
that looks real what the hell leg
i found them i found them guys that were
in ikea they're in the ikea section
hey look cybee you got some credit there
in the cocoa melon
i did not expect those good buildings
god damn
oh my god they made my oh my god
what this is so trippy dude
what stop it this is my oh
no what the hell
oh my god dude it's so precise
this is freaking me out oh my god
what whoa whoa that's so cool
god damn man i'll never
build anything that good guess i
i'm not so good at minecraft after all
guess i'm terrible what is this
nice nice nice nice ikea tower glorious
not as good as mine though that one is
not as good as mine
whoa whoa
whoa look at this little town
it looks so real oh they got all the
flags that's so cool
pewdiepie
i'm blown away dude kakashi on the other
side
so cool you what in the world is this
why did you build this why why
why did you make this oh they used my
house to make it
they no
no i take it back we need to ban the
server
the server was a mistake and so was
anime
ayamiya saki i make the rules a coco
melon temple eh
i see how it is okay this is some
redstone
[Music]
i suppose i press the button
doesn't seem like it's working hey look
it's part of the platypus
now seif doesn't have to edit it in him
in 100 ml baby
stop putting coco man what the hell am i
looking
at ikea tower glorious
one to one scale replica oh whoa we got
a whole
city dude i'm so lost i have no idea
where i am
are we back at the tnt nice no way
dude no way this is so cool
what the sheep temple an actual temple
of water sheep
whoa oh my god
i can't enter oh here we go
oh my god yes
[Music]
wow amazing looks like redstone doesn't
work on other people's plots i said
disappointing i'm sure it played
that no good one
very good one i like that one here we
have the zawardo
give spiderman a little kiss
oh god oh god i didn't realize i could
break them sorry
there we go mega peepee center
nice where you collect your peepees how
do people get bigger plots i didn't even
know that was possible
hey look what brazil made guys very
impressive
oh my god why would you build this why
oh my god why it's making me an awkward
stop
whoever oh no forbidden forbidden
no stop
stop whatever you're doing some dragon
ball
hey we got g fuel oh my god
nice nice nice hey look it's got my face
on it
is that ireland look ireland did nothing
guys i told you bro
i told you yeah it's me and my
tambourine
nice no ricardo
get out of here ricardo stop it
hey look now i can make one of those
memes boom boom
boom i did the meme guys
i did it nice
nice nice you just when you think you've
seen it all another area shows up and
you're like what the
what what oh my god it's the reddit band
hammer
we got all the flags where's the swedish
flag
the ranch we found it that last
it's real the ranch is real they're
caught in the giant peepee tower
whoa god whoa holy
dude motherflippit's statue of liberty
in minecraft
okay hey we got berserk reference damn
oh my god they put a microphase on it
god damn god
damn yeah i can build that
sure nice berserker
slavic paradise nice
whoa what in the world did you build
here oh god
i don't even want to know is this a
roller coaster someone built the roller
coaster
hell yeah i'll try a roller coaster
damn it why a redstone come on give me
redstone
accessibility oh my god it looks so
amazing next time i'll make sure i can
ride these
i'll definitely make another video going
through these again
stop with the thong why
doesn't belong in minecraft no it
doesn't oh my god even the
advanced bills look weak now compared to
the god ones like this is so good
there it is there's a swedish very nice
cocoa bad
cocoa bad go away i love all the
japanese structures so cool
[Laughter]
watersheep mania jeb jeb factory that's
where he was born
we finally have the this makes me want
to build so bad dude
[Laughter]
nice whoa whoa
wow that's so cool oh my god
it's that tower in new york that i don't
know the name of i can feel my heart
crack
oh my never gonna no stop it
whoa nice [ __ ] keep it up guys well done
gang floor 20 decrease oh my god
this man is so cute minecraft needs to
hire you guys
i'm telling you stefano
nice old references nice
like an eight-year-old hello floor gang
it's piggy guys remember piggy oh my god
i love speeds oh my god oh
we got all the legends on the brofist
pixel art
hey peppa made it in almost missed him
this is the doofenshmirtz tower i'm
surprised no one's built it yet
oh sven why are you sad no
can't write poems but you treated him
like [ __ ] so i made him move to the
worst country in scandinavia
denmark said no get out of denmark said
no
i'm coming back soon sven i swear
minecraft come back soon
what god damn i can't that was dead
oh my god oh my god it's george
what
god damn guys oh my god it's got an
inside too
whoa what the sheep throne coming
whoa look at down on that oh
pewdiepie volcano pewdiepie volcano
yes nice there it is
there it is i gotta build that whoa
what even what floor gang nice
jesus christ that's a massive tree dude
nice vaporwave dude that's so cool
swedish castle is that a dollar nice
we had those as our wedding invitations
earlier name plates
oh i wish i could hit it it's glorious
i don't know if i explained but yeah
everyone gets their own set of land
yeah i did say that this is so cool i'm
amazed
i didn't expect these advanced buildings
like this is great i'm all right
you know what i mean everywhere i look
there's an ikea nearby
oh they built a bunch of figurines nice
that's so cool sleepy
peepee peepee series
devil man cry baby reference nice
nice nice
oh my god is that the pewdiepie chair
oh it's not finished sad i would have
loved to sit in it
hey we got a portal reference cool
what in the ever living oh neogenesis
and mcgillian gundam nice
lawyer headquarters it's all happening
here gamers
i'm blown away guys i'm actually blown
away
thank you for all the buildings i hope
you had fun building them
keep making because i keep want to look
at it it's so fun
i'm amazed i'm i'm blown away you blew
my expectations away
well done thank you for everyone joining
the members
tier three it all all goes to charity as
well and we can have the servers up
and do a bunch of fun cool stuff like
this i'm so i'm so happy
keep joining because i'll do another
episode in the future that's it for now
thanks for all the members thanks to you
for everyone hey
ah children of nine parts
it's time to raise what was once
forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
poopty is coming too
nintendo switch
and remember it has a very big tv
pre-order promotion i mean
[Music]
we